necesitamos factorizar 49 que es
cuadrada menos 49 y el cuadrado ahora
aquí hay un patrón con el cual puede que
ya esté familiarizado pero sólo para
asegurarnos de que ya estás vamos a
pensar qué es lo que sucede si
multiplicamos expresiones como las
siguientes tenemos a más b y estos son
solamente dos términos de un binomio que
multiplica a menos b si multiplicamos
estos dos binomios que vamos a obtener
me va a quedar ahora me da a cuadrada
después esto hay que agregarle la
multiplicación de a por menos b lo cual
es menos a b y después a esto hay que
agregarle la multiplicación de b por lo
cual me da a b y para finalizar hay que
agregarle la multiplicación de b por
menos b lo cual me da menos b cuadrado
ahora lo que quiero que veas es que aquí
tenemos un menos a b y un ave positivo
por lo tanto estos dos se cancelan y
simple y sencillamente me queda a
cuadrado menos b cuadrada
perfecto ahora aquí tenemos el mismo
patrón si te das cuenta 49 x cuadrada es
un cuadrado perfecto y 49 cuadrada
también es un cuadrado perfecto es decir
podemos ver a 49 x cuadrada de la forma
7x esto elevado al cuadrado menos 49 y
cuadrada pero 49 y el cuadrado
lo podemos ver de la siguiente manera
esto es lo mismo que tener 7 y elevado
al cuadrado y es justo aquí donde ves el
patrón porque esto es exactamente lo
mismo que tener a cuadrada menos b
cuadrada y por lo tanto lo podemos
factorizar en la siguiente expresión
esto es lo mismo que poner 7 x es a más
ven y entonces a esto hay que sumarle
ven pero ve vale 7 y entonces más 7 y y
después a menos que por lo tanto
cambiamos el color de amd y me queda 7 x
menos b pero b vale 7 y entonces a esto
hay que quitarle el valor de 7
y aquí ya tenemos una factorización de
esta expresión con la que empezamos
justo este es el patrón que se nos
deriva podemos decir ahora hay un camino
alternativo para poder obtener esta
misma factorización que también sería
totalmente legítima nosotros podríamos
desde el inicio factorizar un 49 y que
nos quede 49 que multiplica a su vez a
equis cuadrada menor ya cuadrada y en
este momento cuando tú dices 'wow aquí
está otra vez el patrón esto es lo mismo
que a cuadrada menos de cuadrada por lo
tanto esto es lo mismo que escribir 49
que multiplica a + b pero en este caso a
vale x y b vale y además ven ya esto hay
que multiplicarlo por a menos b es decir
por x menos y seguramente te estás
preguntando si esta factorización y esta
factorización son lo mismo porque aquí
ya acabamos de factorizar y si la
respuesta es que sí porque en este caso
podremos sacar de esta expresión un 7
para fuera y de esta expresión un 7 para
fuera y 7 por 7 me dan este 49 que
tenemos aquí así que estas dos son ambas
formas correctas de factorizar esto